こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さん
ガチャガチャではそんなことあります俺の
子供の頃からガチャガチャが好きで結構
遊んでるんですけどももうここ最近の
令和のガチャすごないですかなんか高いの
だったらもう何円なんだろう一番高い
ガチャガチャって何なんだ調べてみよう
まず一番高いガツガツ出てくる
2500円それぐらいなんかもうガチャの
クオリティも値段もガンガン上がって様々
なガチャガチャが出てくるなんか私見つけ
てしまいました
それ
がこちら
[拍手]
絶対に開かないかジャポン
開けよう
せめてせめてくれよ開かないガシャポンが
売ってました
開かないんですって開かないってこれどう
すればいいの
開かないガシャポンですってもうなんか
怪しい物体なんですけどもてかそもそも
これなかなか手に入んないんですよ静岡だ
と俺調べたところ多分売ってるとこなくて
売り切れてるのか知らないけどわざわざ
このガチャポン越しに
横浜まで行ってきました
[音楽]
どれだろう
どれかなんだよな
[音楽]
ぁどこかにあるって聞いたんだけどな
まだ可愛いどこだどこにあるんだ
各300円
めっちゃ対象年齢高い15歳以上の60
形状は3つですね絶対に開かない
ガシャポン
[音楽]
同じの2個なんだけど
あとレベル1が出れば
レベル1出ないんだけどこんなに開かない
あっても困るな
出た
そうなのよなんか種類が多くて全然種類
じゃなくてすごい数になったんですけど
一応カラーバリエーションが黒と白で
レベル1レベルにレベル3の3種類ある
みたいですちょっとかっこいいので黒3つ
にしましょうか
大きさはかなりばらつきがありますね
レベル1レベルにレベル3開けてみ
ましょう
黒いただの玉だな泥団子え待って待って
音なるんだけど何か入ってるのかなレベル
1ですこれがレベル2
レベル2
なんか線が入ってるんだよな何なんだこれ
そしてレベル3出ました何なんだろうね
なんかでも周りに線みたいなのは見えます
ね一応これで3つで揃いましたレベル1
レベルにレベル3いやー大きさが違うけど
もこれは難易度なのかなさすがにこれが
一番難しそうですねなんか複雑そうな感じ
あるしいやこれすごくねガチャガチャこう
やってレバー回転させてったらこれその
ままボトン落ちてくるんですよこの
カプセル自体が商品っていう普通に頭
おかしい
画期的な発想だと思いますもうカプセル
自体を商品にするっていうちょっと早速
レベル123あるんで絶対開かないんです
よね絶対って言われるとやってみたくなる
のが男の差がレベル1レベル2レベル3
全てやってみたいと思いますでは行こう
[音楽]
ではやっていきたいと思いますまずは
レベル1何入ってんだレベル1やっていき
たいと思いますいやもうねマジで意味
わかんないのよ
簡単そうな気がするんだよね俺は勢いで
いけると思ってる行きます
カラカラしてんのが気になるの絶対開かな
いって大げさ
よ開くぞこれこれも開くぞ
いやここからかここスーってなるんです
けど
[音楽]
力
のやつかパズルみたいなことも書いてない
から力の可能性あるな
[音楽]
ひねっても動かない
からかけるとなんかふってちょっと開く
ぐらい
力なのか
[音楽]
うざっレベル1からうざこのレベルが続く
のこれレベル1で結構渋いんだけどこれ
開かないやんマジで待ってよ
いけそうな気がしてきてる
えこれほんと使うか
[音楽]
あっつい取れちゃう動くんですよそっから
これ無理かちょっと待ってなんかここは
パカパカするのわかるんだけど
[音楽]
なんで開いたえっなんか開いたんだけど
どういうことなにこれあ
分かったわなんかカチャカチャ言ってた
なって思ったんですけどこうやって中で
この棒が
移動してたんですよこうやって俺今
たまたま運よく適当にこう動かせたら
パカって取れただけで
危ないレベル1でこんなことしてくるんだ
多分なんだけど両方のこれが
こっち側に来ないと開かないっていう
仕組みでした
なんか入ってるななんかQRコードが書い
てあった読み込んでみます
なるほど出てきますね
それも溶けてますからわかるんですけど
まあやっぱそうだ開けずに回転させてこの
棒を真ん中に移動させないと開けないと
やつですね俺やっばちょっと
閉めとこうこうやってまた移動させたら
開かなくなった
面白いレベル1でこの面白さでしょう音が
鳴ってるのがポイントでしたね外見だけ見
てても絶対わからないいきなりすごいな
レベル1でしたじゃあ次はレベル2やって
いきたいと思いますレベルにはなんか線が
めっちゃ引いてあるんですよこれなん
だろう
なんか動いたなんか動いてる
何これ
何何何
あ溶けたこれも溶けた溶けたのかないや
待てよなんか
わからんぞまだとりあえずQRコード
読み込んでみますわあークリアです
えなんか俺今
運良く行けたな戻せないもんだってなる
ほどねなんかあれだね
[音楽]
わかんないなんで行けたんだろうすごいね
そんな簡単なやつじゃないぞこれ
うわぁ戻らせましたこれねあれだねあの
うまく言えないんですけど
溝にはめてパカって取れるんですけど
溶かなきゃいけない水が2つ回転させ
なきゃいけない凸が2つそれをこうなんか
あの
ラストレベル3いきましょうではレベル3
いきます最後ですよえー絶対開かないん
ですよね僕今のところほぼ運というか
なんか勢いでクリアできたらこれあるよで
はやっていきましょうお願いしますこれ
クリアできたらもう俺本物よなんかすごい
な
絶対変形する系ですねこれまずどこをどう
動かすかとか音は鳴らない回転する場所が
あるのかないのか
なんか怪しい溝が何これ何これ何これ
何これ
え
キットカットキットカットなのかこれ
キットカットみたいなやつが出てきたこれ
今どういう仕組みだったんだなんか勢いで
取れたけどこれなんかここから動く動き
出してるのあーなんか取れた取れた3
パーツぐらい取れたけどこっから先マジで
わからんぞ
あなんか
取りそう
えーどこから出てきたのちょっと待って俺
なんか知らない間にどんどんポロポロ取れ
てってるけどうわーなんか
おおおおお
おおおお
できたー
どうやって何がどうやってこうなったの
ちょっと調べてみますうんなるほどにゃん
最後のレベル3は完全にパズルですねどう
やってやったんだろう俺
申し訳ないけどこれ俺またやれって言って
も多分無理だよ直せたらまあ理解できて
るって事になるよな
[音楽]
どうやって
はいというわけであの無事クリアはできた
んですけどもどうやって俺クリアできたか
マジでわかんないこれパズルだよもうこれ
めっちゃ複雑やなちょっと戻せるまでやっ
てみるねこれ無理だ
いや皆さんこれね直してたらわかることが
あるんですけど俺多分相当むずいことを
産んでクリアしたわ
チュッパチャップスごめんなさい直せない
です直せません結構時間かけて今直そうと
したんですけども絶対に開かない
ガシャポンまではちょっと行かないかも
しれませんがレベル1から俺はもうねどれ
一つとして
理屈がコーデってわかって得たものが
なかったので実質全廃ですガチャガチャで
こんなに頭使うことないなって思ったので
ちょっと新しい方ですはい皆さんよかっ
たら是非やってみてください手に入らない
かもしれないか